et après le cinéma la scène salle comble
hier soir à bercy plus de 15000
personnes sont venues applaudir le
groupe depeche mode
pour son premier concert parisien né il
y à 12 ans depeche mode est resté
pendant longtemps le symbole de la
musique des années 80 mais le groupe a
évolué ces derniers temps un aperçu du
changement tout de suite avec sophie
guillou édité par an ils sont toujours
quatre il joue toujours sur des
synthétiseurs et ils vendent toujours
autant de disques pourtant depeche mode
a changé question de look d'abord fini
les ados trop bien coiffé place aux
cheveux longs et ont négligé 6
mais la musique aussi a évolué
aujourd'hui timidement les instruments
acoustiques viennent réchauffer leçon
glace et de l'électronique
en ce moment nous avons tendance à
utiliser davantage de répercussions et
de vraies guitares
ce sont des instruments très dynamique
qu'ils apportent un punch qu'on ne peut
pas toujours obtenir avec des
synthétiseurs
mais les synthés peuvent apporter autre
chose et nous ne le renierons jamais
l'utilisation d'électronique un
changement dans la continuité qui semble
plaire au public hier néophyte des
fidèles de longue date communier dans le
même enthousiasme sa première fois
qu'ils avaient une batterie sur scène
vous n'avez jamais eu ça avant et c'est
un événement parce qu'on a vu la
première batterie des notes sur scène en
direct
j'aime beaucoup oui j'ai trouvé que les
jeunes étaient de bonne compagnie là ce
soir et je suis vraiment bien
exit donc le conflit des générations
avec son show bien huilé et sa musique
un peu trop sage depeche mode invente
l'europe du consensus
c'est peut-être ce qui explique sa
longévité douze ans après ses débuts le
groupe coup qu'il n'a pas usurpé son nom
il est décidément toujours à la mode
dans la